before we begin since this is a BBC
owned property I feel the need to point
out that the news armor the BBC has a
continuing issue with transphobic
leanings in its news coverage you can
find in a pinned comment below various
videos from both myself and other
YouTubers covering this issue and while
I understand that the Doctor Who
creative team is not responsible for
this I will continue to point this out
for as long as it remains a consistent
issue thank you
is anybody else getting a weird feeling
of deja vu right now
thank you
so
word is at time of recording I've seen
it reported as rumor I've seen it
confirmed
I'm going to talk about it and roll the
dice that it does not get completely
debunked between now and when I intend
to put this video up which is not
immediately when I shoot it or the news
drops because I'm trying to dial back my
work schedule so I can get other stuff
done that is behind but this
that's my issues anyways word is
that during Russell T Davis new run on
shurigatwa's 15th doctor
that Stephen Moffett is being brought in
to write a story
so this has Garnet a very mixed reaction
and in fact kind of runs the gamut I've
seen people get very excited by this
I've seen people get very nervous about
this I've seen people get confused as to
why people would get nervous and as
someone who
kind of honestly sees both sides of this
maybe I can lay out the whole thing
first of all let's just be open about
the fact some people don't like
Moffitt's work or at least they didn't
like worm off its work ended up his work
initially on Doctor Who was nearly
universally acclaimed I mean look at the
Run he had when he first started under
the period when Russell C Davis was
running the show
the empty child the girl in the
fireplace blink
Forest of the Dead that was pretty
unimpeachable it's a big part of why
people were excited for him to take over
now people do get tired of him but for
the most part that was when he was
running things so while during his time
at showrunner he did do some of my
favorite stories he show ran for my
favorite doctor he also did stuff like
hell bent so you know
mixed bag even someone who liked his era
I acknowledge mixed bag but the thing is
it feels more appropriate to compare
this to when he was writing when RTD was
running things because that's what the
situation would be again
so whatever you feel about where his
writing ended up when he was show runner
and he was also doing multiple things at
the same time for some of those Series
this is going to be much more akin to
when he did what most people agree was
some of his best stuff and consistently
really really good
so that's the reason to be excited
what are the reasons to be nervous
well for me since I do for the most part
like Moffitt's writing especially on
Doctor Who
it's mostly philosophical
because a big part of why I am allowing
myself to get excited about RTD2 and the
shootikatua era is that
I've gone in
assuming and I need to assume this I've
gone in assuming that he's not just
going to come in and do what he did back
in 2006. or five or whenever the heck
the reboot started that he's not just
going to bring that back bring back that
feel and try and recreate what the show
was over a decade ago I am assuming that
and I need that to be true
because
if he is in fact
trying to just recreate what it was
before
I suddenly have much much less interest
despite liking a lot of his era
I always get worried about the show well
any show but especially Doctor Who when
it feels like it's reaching backwards
instead of trying to move forward now
there is an inherent fear that I have
around that with RTD coming back at all
as well as the ReUse of David Tennant
but I've been willing to roll with that
and be cautiously optimistic
on a lot of things that are like just
just barely just barely fitting in a
situation that kind of works for me
in the case of tenant coming back it's a
limited run it's three specials and he's
done great
great I am kind of curious as to what
the story will be and he's not going to
stick around indefinitely okay
let's see what you can do with that
as for our DT
he's grown
as a writer
it's been a long time since he wrote
Doctor Who
I mean like for anything other than like
some internet exclusive stuff
he's changed as an artist he's grown
he's I think he's gotten better in a lot
of ways as a writer
I want to see what RTD now will do with
the material I know what he did with it
back then I don't need more of that
but there's an increasing number of
things that
don't necessarily guarantee that it's
going to be him trying to recapture what
it used to be
but still feel like caution signs to me
one
was us finding out that they're already
working on spin-offs which from a
business perspective I get I did a whole
video talking about all this but in
short
that feels like again trying to
recapture The Glory Days of Doctor Who
and its spin-off and its Universe of
things most of which was under RTD
and I I'm nervous at the idea of jumping
back into that right away partially
because it feels like chasing Old Glory
and partially because I really want them
to just focus on getting the main show
as good as it can be
and now they're also bringing in
a writer
who was also working with RTD during
that era a good writer don't get me
wrong
but it's another thing that feels like
it might not definitely not definitely
but it might
be signaling more interest in
recapturing old stuff than trying to do
new stuff
and then you add in even the temporary
return of David Tennant on top of that
more and more things are adding up and
feel like they are pointing towards
we're gonna make it like it was which I
understand will get a lot of people
excited
but for the health of the property I
don't think that's a good idea
I
almost never think that's a good idea
I will pretty much always Advocate
attempting to move forward as opposed to
trying to grasp and capture something
that you've lost now it can on occasion
work
I still don't think it's the healthiest
for the for the sake of the property I
don't think it's the uh creative most
healthy thing to be doing and
approaching with a mentality but like
it's not impossible to work it's just a
it's a mentality that I'm very very very
wary of
and
I just would have kind of liked RTD to
be the shepherd to watch over and bring
in
some new people some new ideas and maybe
we will still get some people who are
new but bringing in the other biggest
name who was also writing uh at that
time for the show
and like
I get it
I get why some people would take a lot
of comfort in this especially given what
happened during Chipmunks our especially
series 11 which was that he brought in a
writing team
which was pretty much all people who
either didn't have experience in writing
science fiction or didn't have
experience in writing television or
didn't have experience in either one and
while in a couple of instances it did
result in some newer fresher ideas one
of the other practical outcomes of that
was that it resulted in chimnal not
spending much time on his own scripts
because he had to work on fixing up the
scripts that he was given to make them
shooting ready because they were written
by people who couldn't just produce
something that was going to be workable
as a finished script I mean this is part
of why the battlefield ran the Battle of
Ren score of colos ended up the way that
it did it and they effectively shot a
first draft because he was too busy
cleaning up everyone else's scripts to
finish his own
but that was not a problem with the idea
of bringing in newer people with new
ideas that was a problem with the
execution of how he did it and the
specific lineup of people that he did
any one of whom might have been a great
addition but the but the collective
um weight of their inexperience in
either this medium or genre meant that
chimnil couldn't work on his own
freaking stuff
so it's one of those cases where I don't
think it was a bad idea to bring in
newer people just as a broad thing maybe
that specific group
um just again not saying they were bad
writers but like when the show order has
to babysit all of them because they're
not used to working on a product like
this and he also has to produce his own
scripts that was just a bad idea
or that was a bad execution of a
potentially good core idea of bringing
in newer people with new Notions
so the idea of now bringing back Moffat
feels like running away from that and
that may not be the case it may turn out
that Moffett is really the only notable
returning name that we're bringing in
and then it's a bunch of other new
people or maybe Davis is planning to
write more of the scripts himself than
he had previously who knows
if we start getting announcements for
other regular writers like uh Toby
Woodhouse or margadis also coming back
then I am going to genuinely be nervous
and I'm gonna start getting paranoid
and while we're not there yet
this feels like
one more thing that has the potential to
signal
an era that I'm gonna get very
frustrated by
and disappointed by it may not be bad in
any objective measure
but as someone where part of my love of
Doctor Who
stems not from the fact that I grew up
on it as a kid I didn't
I discovered it in my 20s
and part of the reason I fell in love
with it was because of the breadth of
possibility
the fact that it could go anywhere
any when
tell any story
have any possible future Direction and
sometimes yeah those directions went
places that didn't work
but the near infinite possibility of
Doctor Who
is a big part of what I love about it
and seeing more and more
and more
signals
that they're gonna try and just
recapture the Old Glory
that's not moving forward into infinite
possibilities that's doing what Star
Trek did for decades
do you know how long Star Trek went
without moving its own timeline forward
do you know how long Voyager was the
furthest into the future that franchise
went because they decided to go with
prequels and reboots and refuse to go
forward in any way now whatever you
think of things like Picard that have
brought things further forward and also
capitulating the fact that some of the
um the retreat or prequels stuff such as
say strange new worlds is really good
but that was a really long period
without like this is the embodiment of
spinning your wheels because you don't
know where to go
that was also the period in which I had
the least interest in anything Star Trek
was doing
I've got more interest in it now and
honestly if something like Picard didn't
exist I might not be as into strange new
worlds as I am
it helps that I know somewhere the
franchise is trying to move forward
even if my pin just fell off yeah
I'll find it later
but you know even if things are circling
back
as long as some part of it is trying
to go forward to explore the
possibilities of not looking back but
looking ahead
in some way whether it be by literally
finally moving the timeline forward with
the card or exploring different genres
with things like lower decks
that gives me reassurance that I can
enjoy something that is a little bit
more of a throwback like strange new
worlds because I know that's not the
only thing the thing's doing
and maybe with the spin-offs with the
other things Doctor Who will create a
situation where some of it moves forward
some of it looks back
and maybe it'll work
granted not all of this is happening at
once as I said tenants on a limited run
he's not staying around forever we'll
we'll have shooty got one maybe he'll
bring such a different energy on the
part that it'll help carry things and
have them feel new regardless of the
state of the actual scripts being
written
Maybe
and maybe the scripts even from old
hands like RTD and Moffett will still
feel new and fresh
but it's getting to a point where it is
starting to feel like putting on
blinders to just assume that's going to
be the case
the people being announced the people
involved are very good have been very
good
and yet I am still nervous
we'll see
I don't know and we'll see
what are your thoughts about any of this
whatever they are drop something down in
the comments let's talk about it patreon
pays the bills and enables me to do this
as my living any amount you can uh throw
me that way is of great assistance plus
you get perks at every tier but uh don't
worry too much about it
what I really want you to remember
is whether you're excited whether you're
nervous whether anything about what's
coming up
you are beautiful
you are valid
and you are loved
you are the council I'm just running the
meeting and until next time this Council
is adjourned I also put the ring on the
wrong finger I normally do it on the
left
which is I'm just a mess today
[Music]
this video wouldn't have been possible
without my supporters over on patreon
and I would especially like to thank
Robin Moore Zubin look fola Tarak the
thing that goes doink in the anime Ruth
Oliver B
ulurik Bogdan Melinda Walters imudelki
Theo the Boyd Auntie Kate 808 Becky
Sparks bernabe likes the poodle Robin
Powell Tracy scrabot angry Casper Tim
price Adam r d l Taylor David Hall
General contact unit Problem Child
Shayla gourlay and Rosalind Bennett
thank you so much
[Music]
oh